[Musique]
j'ai peur
j'ai pas confiance du tout et je me sens
pas du tout légitime
je suis sûr que vous avez déjà eu cette
petite voix dans votre tête qui vous
empêche de concrétiser vos idées les
plus folles et vos projets les plus fous
c'est pareil pour moi
je n'ai pas du tout confiance et j'en
perds complètement mon texte alors que
ça fait 30 secondes que je suis là
donc je vais reprendre c'est idées sont
des peurs totalement immatériels en fait
et pourtant elles ont un impact très
concret dans notre vie réelle vous venez
d'avoir
la présentation
en fait
genre il y a pas longtemps on m'a dit
tu as de la chance Ariane d'avoir
confiance en toi
tu n'as pas peur que ça ne marche pas
et c'est vrai qu'en fait c'était la
c'est une chose que j'aurais pu dire à
quelqu'un qui du jour au lendemain se
lance un nouveau challenge
mais quand on me demande si je n'ai pas
peur
que ça ne marche pas et bien j'ai envie
de vous dire j'ai totalement peur et un
moment j'arrête tout et je retourne dans
quelque chose que je connais et que je
maîtrise
[Musique]
et ce qui me fait encore plus rire c'est
quand on me dit que j'ai confiance en
moi parce que franchement sur l'échelle
admettons de 0 à 100 l'échelle de la
confiance je dirais que je suis à moins
j'ai pas du tout confiance en moi
j'ai pas le droit de toucher le micro
non plus
comment se fait-il qu'un jour je décide
de me lancer et de me lancer dans le
grand bain et de me mettre à mon compte
en fait est-ce que la confiance en soi
c'est un bagage qu'on a dès qu'on arrive
au monde et soit ta confiance en toi et
c'est super montagne tu graviras soit tu
as pas du tout confiance en toi et mal
barré tu sauras comme moi
où est-ce que le la vie le parcours les
expériences va faire que tu vas pouvoir
la bâtir en toi à cette confiance
ok je sais pas est-ce que enfin pourquoi
un jour je me suis réveillé je me suis
dit tiens je vais me lancer c'est une
super idée
en fait c'est un parcours qui a vraiment
mis beaucoup de temps à être construit
mais si vraiment aujourd'hui je devais
dire le déclic qui a fait que je me
lance je dirais qu'en fait ça a été la
rencontre
la vie a mis sur mon chemin une personne
exceptionnelle qui avait un style de vie
totalement différent de la mienne c'est
un entrepreneur et moi autour de moi
j'avais pas du tout ce schéma là plutôt
chez ma classique
et donc cette entrepreneur m'a pris sous
son aile et on a beaucoup beaucoup
échangé et c'est devenu une grande
source d'inspiration pour moi
même un mentor je dirais
et c'est comme ça que je me suis lancée
trop bien
sauf qu'en fait bah non pas trop bien
parce que c'était très très compliqué
ce jeter comme ça dans le vide être face
à l'inconnu il y a rien de plus
inconfortable
et c'est
bloquant j'ai eu beaucoup de peur
beaucoup de doutes et en fait j'ai le
début de mon expérience de
l'entrepreneuriat a été très long remise
en cause sur moi introspection
et j'avais l'impression de pas du tout
avancer en fait
du coup j'ai voulu réitérer
ce l'expérience de la rencontre parce
que ça m'avait tellement apporté que je
me suis dit qu'il fallait que j'aille
chercher à nouveau cette motivation et
cette inspiration en allant rencontrer
des gens
c'est comme ça que j'ai créé un podcast
pour aller à la rencontre des
entrepreneurs de Lille mais surtout des
entrepreneuses de la Réunion
pour pouvoir vraiment être inspiré de ce
qu'elles font et connaître leur parcours
et je l'ai vraiment fait dans une
volonté pour moi parce que je savais que
ça allait m'apporter énormément et comme
je me dis que je dois pas être la seule
à ressentir ça j'avais envie aussi de le
partager pour peut-être des personnes
qui
à des moments de leur vie ont moins
confiance et perdre cette motivation
alors je crée le podcast et je vais
rencontrer des personnes que j'admire à
travers ce qu'ils font et ce qu'ils sont
et au fil des échanges avec eux vous
serez hyper étonné parce qu'en fait ou
pas mais moi j'ai été étonné
ce qui est beaucoup ressorti dans les
épisodes c'est qu'ils ont peur ils ont
des doutes le syndrome de l'imposteur
est toujours là
ils font des erreurs ils ont ils ont
beaucoup d'échecs ils font des
sacrifices
donc je me dis
mais c'est bizarre ils font des choses
incroyables ils se lancent ils vont au
bout et pourtant
ils ont peur
donc moi ça m'a beaucoup rassuré
beaucoup déculpabiliser
et quand je leur demandais s'ils avaient
confiance en eux
en fait la confiance elle n'était pas du
tout au rendez-vous
alors je me suis dit que
il faisait des choses incroyables malgré
les doutes malgré la peur malgré le
manque de confiance
et pourtant il réussissait donc
qu'est-ce qui faisait qu'ils y aller en
fait
moi je suis repartie dans une
introspection parce que les
introspections c'est toute ma vie
donc
je me suis rendu compte que la confiance
en soi j'avais vraiment nourri beaucoup
de croyances autour de ça j'avais un peu
des projections des illusions autour de
ça et je me suis je pensais sincèrement
que si on n'avait pas confiance en soi
mais on serait mal barré toute sa vie
et bah là on venait de me prouver le
contraire
ok alors c'est quoi l'autre chose
qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière j'ai voulu
déconstruire tout ça et aujourd'hui je
vous le partage ce qui en ressort c'est
que en fait je pense que la confiance en
soi ça ne va pas garantir un résultat
donc si tu as super confiance en toi
c'est cool mais ça veut pas dire que tu
vas réussir mais l'inverse est super
chouette en tout cas c'est une très
bonne nouvelle parce que si on n'a pas
confiance en soi bah ça veut pas dire
qu'on ne va pas réussir
et ça moi j'adore l'idée
et ce qui en est ressorti aussi un point
très important c'est que souvent
j'entends oui et je suis la première à
le dire oui mais j'ai une super idée
j'ai envie de la lancer mais je manque
de confiance en moi j'ai pas assez
confiance et cetera et cetera
mais le problème dans tout ça c'est que
si on l'attend elle va jamais arriver en
fait
je connais personne qui s'est assis a
attendu et la confiance elle est arrivée
du coup
bah je suis désolé de vous l'apprendre
mais je pense que la meilleure façon
c'est de se faire violence et ouais on
n'aime pas ça nous les humains sortir de
du cadre et être confronté à ses peurs
comme moi là maintenant
du coup
il faut se faire violence imaginez une
roue
la roue de la confiance qui est statique
qui bouge pas ok on a envie d'avoir
confiance donc faut la faire tourner qui
peut la faire tourner
vous exactement
il faut la première impulsion pour
qu'elle tourne et puis qu'après waouh ça
continue
première impulsion et c'est parti ou
alors imaginez que vous avez je
m'adresse à ceux qui ont pas confiance
en eux ou alors vous avez pas du tout
confiance imaginez que vous avez une
graine en vous la graine de la confiance
est chez vous bon pas de chance elle
sait pas elle a pas poussée bah pour
aller la faire pousser fleurir la faire
grandir mais il faut aller l'arroser et
bah il y a que vous qui peut faire ça
quand je me suis lancée dans ma première
activité c'était des illustrations et
j'ai jamais fait de cours de dessin
d'études là-dedans enfin voilà donc je
me sentais pas du tout à ma place donc
quand il a fallu montrer ce que je
faisais c'était très compliqué pour moi
bon je j'ai réussi à le faire
c'était très dur et en fait quelque
chose au début qui paraît totalement
insurmontable devient naturel vraiment
je fais l'expérience maintenant ça va
très bien
tout ça pour vous dire que j'ai
déconstruit et je me suis fait violence
mais ça ne résout pas le problème de la
définition c'est quoi en fait avoir
confiance en soi
moi je voulais trouver une définition
qui me parle qui raconte ce que je vais
ce que j'ai vécu qui résonne en moi donc
je suis allée chercher parce que je l'ai
pas trouvé en moi je suis allée chercher
chez des philosophes
des entrepreneurs
et il y a quelque chose qui m'a un
discours qui m'a interpellé c'est le
discours de David Laroche donc c'est un
entrepreneur et coach qui lui dit qu'en
fait dans ces coachings il utilise plus
du tout la notion de confiance en soi
parce qu'en fait la confiance en soi
c'est le fait de ne pas avoir peur
l'absence de peur un peu inhumain je
trouve mais bon je connais pas et par
contre il préfère se baser sur la notion
du courage parce que le courage c'est
même si on a peur bah on y va quand même
comme moi quand j'ai franchi la porte
donc waouh ok il y a le courage j'y
avais pas pensé ça c'est clair et ça
s'illumine dans ma tête je me dis qu'il
y a quelque chose à creuser du coup je
continue mes recherches et je tombe sur
un livre il est incroyable je vous
conseille c'est le livre de la confiance
en soi de Charles Pépin où il va définir
plusieurs il va donner plusieurs
définitions et vision de ça de la
confiance mais celle qui m'a interpellé
que j'ai décidé de garder en moi c'est
qu'en fait la confiance en soi
c'est pas le fait de d'avoir 100%
confiance en soi et d'être sur à 100%.
mais c'est de trouver d'avoir le courage
d'affronter ses peurs et de trouver
justement dans le doute la force de
s'élancer
tout est dit je pourrais m'arrêter là en
gros c'est définition elle illustre
parfaitement ce que vivent les
entrepreneurs et ce que je vis j'ai peur
j'ai des doutes j'ai pas du tout
confiance et pourtant je le fais
waouh incroyable
et je vous dis tout ça parce qu'en fait
je pensais avant que la conscience en
soi c'était le
l'élément clé à avoir pour créer et
faire des choses super dans sa vie enfin
en tout cas répondre à ses envies
alors qu'en fait je pense qu'il y a
vraiment plein d'autres valeurs autour
qui peuvent nourrir cette confiance
comme le courage
donc je pense que si comme moi vous
n'avez pas la graine qui a germé et que
vous n'avez pas non plus les fondations
solides la stabilité nécessaire pour
affronter tout ça
et bien c'est pas grave ça va très bien
se passer parce que je pense qu'on peut
se nourrir des autres rencontrer des
personnes qui nous inspirent qui nous
motivent ça il y a rien de plus fort que
cette énergie positive qui entraîne et
qui nous fait évoluer
je pense que se faire violence c'est
horrible à dire c'est très dur à le
faire mais si la confiance elle ne
garantit pas un résultat moi je vous
garantis que demain vous faites violence
vous passez à l'action vous allez en
savoir beaucoup plus sur vous-même et
pourquoi c'est important d'en savoir
plus sur soi parce que nos peurs ouais
qui sont tout le temps là et ben on va
pouvoir les apprivoiser savoir qui elles
sont et comment les gérer trouver les
moyens de les affronter
alors du coup aujourd'hui quand on me
dit tu as de la chance d'avoir confiance
en toi t'as pas peur que ça ne marche
pas et ben j'ai envie de vous dire que
si j'ai hyper peur et à tout moment
j'arrête tout pour retourner dans
quelque chose que je maîtrise et que je
contrôle
mais j'ai un peu de courage pour
affronter ses peurs les faire taire au
maximum
pour y aller
je ne dirais pas que je suis consciente
mais je dirais que je suis courageuse
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]